date night how are you yeah we run Z
it's the last thing I saw you're in the
pool oh yeah listen I've seen you since
but what I know you were worried we saw
it on the show about releasing new music
and getting back into this world how was
the reaction when Ashley because people
love it it's great we're having so much
fun and I think just that like now it's
out there just feels so good and yeah
we're having fun making music together
and looking forward to touring together
so what's happening with the tour we're
gonna go on a tour in the yeah so we're
looking at dates right now we're trying
to plan out the kids schedule so they
could be on tour with us too okay so
listen I saw Tracy yesterday at the
carpet roll out she's old hat now with
this you know but like did she come to
you for advice do you tease her do you
give her a text message like good luck
are you like don't fall over yeah I gave
her a text message I told her I was
taking over her dressing room cuz I
heard she's got a big dress we won't
really be but you know we're definitely
going in there today no I'm stealing the
dress
told me she's like stealing things from
Diana all the time and like outfits and
she's like I don't even know what's mine
and what's hers and I was like oh my so
have you stolen anything I can I borrow
things I feel like I brought a beautiful
yellow dress yeah you're like may I
please borrow this like how does that
work yeah yeah no yeah she's got so much
amazing stuff in there I try to steal
stuff I'm like I'm definitely the one
like emminster is very like what can we
do I want the coats
actually you don't know this but the
last time I saw you I was like you know
what's coming up for the future and you
were like more babies so you can't write
you the pressure is on it's on no it's
definitely more babies in the future for
sure right now we're finished um and
then yeah more babies making babies
you're about to be auntie again no I'm
excited yeah it was such a great
surprise yeah we're all so excited and
how is she feeling and great doesn't
even great she's always a great pregnant
lady of though she's the youngest what
do you do like do you have a baby
sprinkle or like you're you spoiler and
we do like a fun Michelle we're gonna do
something she's always done mine so I
definitely will be you know taking part
in that so yeah I love that so much
please tell me about this dress I'm
wearing Monique Lhullier and and you
know what tonight I wanted to match my
husband so he's ins well she matched me
tonight no and I'm sorry yeah no no I'm
always second but I think but I was like
oh when I saw this on him it was like
okay blue is that's it tonight I don't
know it maybe it was it I think she
looks amazing
will you give me an arat narrative of
this like break this down for it down
her look for us like you're the reporter
I feel like you got that ocean dripping
down to the toes looking sexy as can be
[Music]